Lastly, the interpreter
does a look-up for
foil, which falls out of the local
scope, but is found in the middle scope.
Note that we're showing this fall
through all in one step, but
it requires a scan of the blue context,
just as before.
The interpreter is done with look-ups,
and
it sends the full concatenated string
as output to the log in system.
This was also the last line of the
function, so the interpreter can jump
back out to where that function was
called and resume processing from there.
Along with it,
the focal context will shift out to
what it was before the red context.
Up until this point,
the picture of the in memory contexts on
the right has shaped up to look really
similar to the picture of
the lexical scope on the left.
The only difference so far has been that
there are actual values visible here,
and in our code,
of course, there are none.
But both of them show one blue
scope inside one red scope,
inside one green scope.
So what's the difference between
in memory scopes and lexical ones?
This starts to become clearer when
saga runs for the second time.